première question mais vraiment la
question qu'on type est-ce que tu
préfères ton père ou ta
mère j'avais dit que c'étais con hein
c'est ça c'est un piège à rat ça ouais
c'est pas possible je peux pas répondre
à ça ça non je peux pas je suis moi
j'aimerais pas comme la peau je serai
drôement merdé bah ouais quoi ça dépend
des moments de ma vie ouais waouh pe pas
faire ch entre ses parents ah si faut je
préfère les deux j'ai pas de choix c'est
dur ça je vous réponds les deux mon
général la mère jusqu'à 14 ans le père
après bonne
réponse le père est vivant père est
vivant ma mère par la force des
choses non non moi
j'étais fils à maman je suis
partagé ma mère ah ou vous dites
carrément vous j'adorais mon père mais
je préférais ma mère
c'est interview nul je vous ai prévenu
je préférre mes grand-mères pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce
bleu